hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video auf meinem kanal meine liebe
freunde wir immer wieder sehen können 70
nicht alleine sondern hh vor einigen
wochen haben sein und ich schon ein
video hochgeladen in dem wir
kinderserien tvn verraten haben da hat
sandra leider gewonnen deswegen wollte
ich unbedingt eine revanche und wir
machen die jetzt heute ja schöner wenn
du nicht verlierst die 1000 lazytown 10
geht schon gut los fragt euch übrigens
bitte nicht warum hier jetzt
beispielsweise nummer 58 steht oder so
mbm spielen dort weiter wo wir letztes
mal mehr oder weniger aufgehört haben
also wir machen das gleiche video und
dann könnte
[Musik]
das kindern das kennt man die hitze
nicht die alle wind alter also steht
immer noch 1 0 für mich normal normal
normal
ja natürlich
das war das was so dass wirklich einfach
schön das ist wirklich die aus schuldet
der ganzen brief ist nach seien richtig
ich will jetzt auch nicht irgend welchen
namen rein werden absolut keine ahnung
was man kennt diese figuren aber was
immer salami lessard agentur ist du mal
so biller niemals so kommt ein puffer
und mogli alter
die noch jung 2 0 1
[Musik]
das war ich dass ich das was hilft ist
das war ich alter
[Musik]
jetzt fängt ein neues leben
ich weiß dass auch gott das ist perry
der oder sei es dass der haben musik
kommt mir bekannt vor gedacht dass ich
da verrate oberallgäu leiter dieser
bears dass auch ein paar richtig sicher
safe steht vier zu eins kann ich sagen
wenn das schon steht es aber ich kannte
die serie aber chris kein punkt dafür
gerade er steht 5 zu 1 sandra was los
mit dir
violinistin und cilic ich glaube diese
gast des lean on stage ist aber ich
glaube es ist irgendwas mit steffi jones
ich habe aber zuerst gesagt ich habe es
zuerst die lunge gelangen
ich habe eine wiederholung
und 16
bei beiden punkten bei den punkt warum
ja kommt dann kriegst du ja das war der
böse wird wie ich das weil die
logistische sollte davon eine schwester
von below
die hat keine mutter stimmt dass die
russen schwester stimmt
[Musik]
101 dalmatiner das auch schon wieder gas
detektiv kronen oder hatte ich früher so
angst vor diesen komischen schwarzen
gestalten die der helaba dargestellt
habe eine ahnung ich habe sowieso nie
anime geguckt anime geguckt was nur tina
gesagt den punkt richtig 62 für mich er
sagt schon genug gewürdigt aus dass du
in ein zwei sekunden erlebt dass bibi
und tina ist vor bibi und tina
ausgesprochen worden ist
das sind natürlich alles klar oder die
ganze scheiße war
[Musik]
sandra t
72 hast du vielleicht nur zwei mitleids
punkte bekommen mit tim einen
youtube-kanal darum dass die ohne
schalter yukio krank trank ich wollte
immer diese durch das kam nie bekommen
alle zwischen anmerkungen bevor das
video gleich weiter geht es gibt noch
restbestände von dem neuen dick und doof
folie und dem neuen dick und doof t
shirt beide sachen sind limitiert was
sollen die leute vergessen machen in der
ukraine shop.de gehen und kaufen dank
[Musik]
des wochenendes mit tino und cover mit
cover der user wieder
jeder hat er in der schule hat mich
martino genannt weil mein zweiter name
ist thilo aber ich war früher mal aus
wie tino und habe mich in einer matinee
hey ich bin ja wunderbar am rasieren
warte ist es denn überhaupt das wort und
gibt's das video das ist klar das ist
eine griechin hitze nicht oder also
nicht um die hier das war so dieses
coole mädchen in der truppe die kurz
truppe
sie hat mir richtig rum an alter noch
eine kleine rote sandstein mein gott das
ein richtig harter hund alter da unten
riecht einfach der hausmeister sie dass
wir uns weiter um die frau von ali k
kommt da zum us-markt aber im endeffekt
niemand eine mächtige magische energie
der kraftstrom ist so stark dass er
mächtig football okay das war's dann
doch nicht kenne ich nämlich auch nicht
aber man kennt das nicht
[Musik]
denn später krass locker zu voll viele
die dieses video schauen sagen
mich hat das nie getan ich war immer
mehr pokémon und junioren dreck die
monkees wissen aber dragonball habe ich
nicht genug dieses anime so wie ich
schon gesagt habe sowieso nie geguckt
alter wie steht's eigentlich 9 zu 3 oder
[Musik]
oder
hatten wir das nicht schon einmal die
plate ich schwöre ich glaube ich habe
auch schon überlegt seiner film sabrina
hatten wir glaube ich schon im ersten
teil wo wir das gemacht haben
bis 14
ich habe aber immer noch sechs
matchbälle
[Musik]
als ultimativer rohstoffpreise gesagt
gleise
nein
dann so zwei ich würde also zwei
zwillinge die haben so eine lernfähige
schwester weitermachen immer so zwei
sind zurzeit die liebeskranke
experimente
das heißt fängt es an ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke nochmal für deine tipps dadurch
habe ich jetzt gewonnen meine lieben
freunde 10 zu irgendwas gegen sandra ich
hoffe die jetzt auch wieder spaß gemacht
letztmals tour gewonnen hat habe ich
gewonnen er also ein finaler haben wollt
also einen dritten teil kinderserien tv
interesse raten mit seinen lukas einem
daumen hoch und ein video davon irrt
gern meinen kanal wenn ihr was machst du
ich habe mir das video mal zu ändern
[Musik]
und was ist schon wieder vergessen bist
du jedes stimmt da egal wenn etwa drei
jahren wollte
[Musik]